[Music]
it's learning on the job from now on I'm
really under pressure
lunchtime service is starting and all
the sushi here is made to order it's a
full house and there's nowhere to hide
Karazhan puts me on the scallop nigiri
and the gear is a simpler rice based
sushi with a fish on top my first
attempt is embarrassing chef Tara Sam
has to step in to help me out he can
make 6 pcs a minute and everyone is
perfect oh my god did different steps is
extraordinary I tried to give it one
more shot
[Music]
and Cara sans patience with me starts to
pay off maybe I'm not so bad at this
after all next an order for spicy tuna
rolls containing tuna chili powder
cucumber and sesame seeds it's made
using a similar technique to the dragon
roll array has to be so exactly the same
size but that took me 13 minutes this
morning have I improved they are all
time there at last done and in under two
minutes
[Applause]
so [ __ ]
finally I think I've cracked it and what
did the punters think last sushi done
I know slightly slow but in terms of the
method it's very precise can I come back
excellent thank you
that was [ __ ] impressive bloody hard
work but I can really start to
understand why it takes so long to
become a top sushi chef today the proof
was in the sushi